yo don't check out a jewelry show too
I can't do that one first
[Music]
what's going on GQ it's your boy little
TZ and you're watching on the rocks
[Music]
first piece of Jerry I'm gonna start
what is this ring this star ring is
actually a ring that I had probably like
two 3DS I see a lot of people posting
about them like they bad like I see
Memes and stuff like that I don't really
wear it like that I don't really caught
Rings Rings is not my thing for two
reason one I have a history of losing
rings and then two when like I got like
on some tight jeans or some of my
marriage and especially if I got
some money digging in my pockets to be
annoying yo
[Music]
to come right now I got him I want to
buy one I got one on the way right now
but I got about four or five Cubans
unfortunately the police got like three
or four Cubans a month
I feel like before my situation I was
moving tack but life happens I feel like
anything that's meant to happen is going
to happen with that being said I just
you know life goes on it's crazy because
a lot of people say like they kind of
misconstrue and they try to say like
I've been I was robbed and stuff for my
change I actually never got wrong for my
change the police took my chains on my
safe after I got shot and so today I
still didn't get them back I heard them
and get them back soon but they got a
big TJ chain I had it for like about a
week or two before
no and God took it from me
and I had a trench kid chain CEO
trench kid is my record label this is
trench kid logo this chain of course
a lot oh yeah this is what it's three or
four Rose links and then a white
Infinity all the way across it's one of
them
calm chain I had the same for like about
three years I just put this on a new
appendix you know mix and match
sometimes and they got the same watches
me assault Richard milley on 41.
yo I think my my jewelry about to come
in right now y'all trying to get on my
chair real quick
yeah that's that chain I was talking
about
1000 grams four kilo it's kind of
similar to the one I had before got a
sturdy back up you know what I'm saying
every angle tell them what type of cube
in this is so this is a fully handset
micro pave Iced Out kilo chain made from
14 karat white gold and we got the
custom NYC luxury lock on it what do you
think about it it's valid I wanna know
you know you could do like for this I'm
saying a little discount on her nobody
we can meet in the middle somewhere you
know you've been shopping with me for
years I gotta show love
Valley
yeah we could do that
I was looking at this this right
here say quiet these braces is like you
know Archie this one's official so we
did was it's a custom cross bracelet so
every other link is across and then you
know your life is Victorious so we try
to do the victory V's as the links and
then put the crosses with the big stones
in the middle and then emeralds to lock
it all up
got a little one two ice
this right here is my first ever watch I
ever got was with this guy right here
too it was I'm a white AP or white I had
the upgrade for me still years ago but
upgraded to White and Rose but yeah this
right here this is a a very important
watch to my life this was always like my
favorite watch he went heavy right away
I remember getting that call from Izzy
like oh TJ's about to spend a bag with
us think of my upgrading again give me
something new when I first got in the
game the first piece of jewelry I copped
was the star ring talking about I had
also had a little chain that said little
sbtj I thought it was so icy I think I
paid like five six thousand for it I
think I got wrong but it was like five
six thousand it was a nice little small
chain it was valid for without Ford I
was doing at the time if you put your
business like always bro you know the
Vlog bro first you want to do it on GQ
don't forget that facts facts
oh no honestly like as much as I like
Flex my jewelry and show it off as much
I'm kind of chill about it I don't
really care too much I definitely know
it's more like smarter things I could do
with my money if you can't do it or you
know what I'm saying don't do it but
me I'm young
say I'm living life I know I'm VI so
he's shining yo it's your boy little TJ
Man album now make sure you go with
that
GQ yeah
foreign